so i'm very interested
in the nature of
burning man specifically the nature of
the states of consciousness that burning
man
gives rise to what are the
underlying mechanics what are the
underlying
principles behind the states of
awareness and suggestibility and
openness
that seemed to be par for the course of
this enchanted
place people talk about playa moments
people talk about
evanescent lightning bolts of meaning in
the perceiver's mind eric davis
says juxtaposition is the formal
operating space of synchronicity he
posits that it is perhaps the
juxtaposition of all this
artwork and creativity against or
juxtaposed against the backdrop of this
desert
that impregnates the objects within it
with a kind of
halo and a kind of enchantment
and it's really something to behold but
i would go
farther in my speculation about how
consciousness is stewarded in
burning man i think burning man deploys
um the power of signaling
the power of prompts to prompt people
into heightened awareness and
receptivity
uh if you think of the way we use
signaling and prompts in the default
world most prompts
and signaling at least in the mechanics
of everyday life are like
do not enter open from 11 to 5.
violators will be prosecuted the world
is
impregnated with a lexicon of signaling
that just
constantly giving you warnings and and
constantly
warning you about the impending doom or
consequences that follow
the the carefree trespass into the
forbidden
forbidden areas right whereas at burning
man our
our experience of the field of awareness
is one in which we are constantly
prompted into heightened awareness with
signaling that says things like
everything you're looking for is inside
of you you might be crisscrossing
through the desert on your electric bike
and then you see an artwork by olivia
steele which is basically giant
typography
on the desert with a sign that says
you're perfect just the way you are
and so imagine your field of awareness
now you're in an alien
environment with a desert backdrop and
incredible
and creative objects manifested on the
scene and all of a sudden you are
prompted
with words with language that says
everything
you want is inside of you and the world
is full of magic
things patiently waiting for our senses
to grow
sharper and so what is being leveraged
at burning man what is being leveraged
is the power of feedback loops
what is being leveraged is the awareness
uh that consciousness is a collaboration
between subject
and object that that we don't end at the
end of our
skin tissue and that are that our field
of awareness that are mind screen that
our subjective
experience is mediated by what we
interface and
interact with and therefore by
judiciously designing the props
the things in the world that we
interface with so that they signal back
to us messages of encouragement and
receptivity and openness
it hurls us into a domain where we
re-enchant the world
the world is re-enchanted and
re-sacralized the world becomes
a dr seuss story oh all the places will
go
that feeling as a child of a world full
of promise a world that was enchanted
and beckoning
right the world that was full of clues
and you could read your way through it
as stephen johnson says
all of a sudden is given rise to so
you're at
burning man but you've been essentially
you've been essentially portaled into a
childlike state of wonderment and
reverie
where all the dots are connecting and
you're in a state of pronoia
where the universe is conspiring you to
shower you with blessings you know and
so
that feeling of enchantment is akin to
an altered state of consciousness but
it's not
it's not somehow it's not fake
it's not fraudulent it's not unreal
in the sense of something to be
dismissed but rather it points the way
to how all
consciousness and awareness is
ultimately stewarded
the way we see the world can be
programmed can be
signaled can be crafted into being and
so burning man becomes a portal or a
mirror
of the way things might be if only we
were aware enough
to steer our mind screen to heaven on
earth which goes back to the whole idea
that like in the end of the day
it's about finding a way of seeing the
world with new eyes but rather than
relying on
a bumper sticker that doesn't give you
the protocols and procedures for doing
so
what i'm actually saying is burning man
could be a laboratory
for paying attention to how signaling
and prompts and
and design cues can steer awareness
towards blissful mind body states of
reverence from where we can source
from the holy and heal our fractures and
so burning man does
this through deep play through through
like the concocting of a psychedelic
wonderland
taking taking cues from the
situationists you know this
radical groups in europe that used to do
things like go to paris with a map of
london
to invert the world and create a
topsy-turvy state of awareness by
tweaking certain things
and tweaking the maps we use and
ultimately that's what it's about and
that's why burning man is a place
where we get to have the actual
experience of magic
we get to experientially receive what
it's like to live in a world
that is actually enchanted and
it's an irresistible feeling people who
have gone there
they know it well they'll say oh you
have to go there to know there
to have those playa moments and those
divinations full of poetry and grace but
i recommend it
and i hope that burning man well i hope
it comes back
on the other side of this pandemic and
more people get to experience such a
magical
place and space